KEVIN MCDONAGH:
I'm Kevin Mcdonogh.
I'm CEO at Novoda.
And Novoda are the world's most
ambitious product engineers.
This means that we understand
product holistically
through our expertise
in engineering.
We work closely with our clients
to build cutting-edge apps that
drive their business goals.
RYAN BATEMAN: I'm the
head of product at Novoda.
We focus on building really
high quality products,
and we're really excited to
work with the Google Developers
Agency Program.
KEVIN MCDONAGH: We're
one of the very few
Google-certified
agencies in the world.
This means that we have an
established relationship
with Google, and have met
that demanding criteria
for the certification.
For one, it gives
us early access
to tools that mean we can
build better, smarter apps
for our clients.
RYAN BATEMAN: And we are
really excited to be involved,
as we knew it would give us new
tools to help make our client's
product even better.
One of these products
was CCleaner.
KEVIN MCDONAGH: Piriform, one of
the companies behind CCleaner,
they knew that we
could understand
their technically-focused users
and help them make this product
super successful on Android.
RYAN BATEMAN: CCleaner
is a utility app.
It's designed to keep your
phone in a more high performance
state.
For example, by getting rid of
old files you no longer need.
It also informs the user.
By giving them more
information about the phone,
they can actually make better
choices around how they use it.
NEIL HUTCHINSON:
CCleaner on Android
is now a huge success with
more than 50 million downloads
on the platform
since its launch.
As it's grown, it's
expanded to reach
types of users we hadn't
originally considered.
Users who want to keep
the phone working well but
aren't interested
in technical detail.
QI QU: We were faced with design
new features easily understood
by the average users
but with enough depth
to still appeal to the
app's core technical users.
NEIL HUTCHINSON: The Google
Developers Agency Program
meant that we had early
access to the new Firebase
Analytics and remote config.
This helped us to set
up effective A/B tests
to better understand
our user base,
how different
segments use the app,
and where we could
better improve each one.
QI QU: It also
means we can begin
to validate alternative designs
with our real existing user
base.
We now have a way
to really understand
what impact any
changes we make we have
before we roll them out to all
50 million of the app users.
RYAN BATEMAN: The
developer agency program
has given us tools and knowledge
to make better products,
and we want to share that
knowledge with others.
We've also begun creating
a smart TV platform backed
by Firebase called Ten Foot TV.
We're really excited to see
its functionality extended
to big screen devices.
KEVIN MCDONAGH: Thanks to
the Google Developer Agency
Program, we've been
able to make CCleaner
a better, smarter
product for our clients
and its millions of users.
We're really excited to continue
to be part of the program.
And we're looking
forward to working
with Google and our
clients to bring even more
fantastic products to market.